[Music]
welcome to new gaming Network did you
know that you'll guaranteed 36 exotic
caches per week I'll go into more detail
on that soon with this video I want to
cover exotics or more specifically how
to get them even now in 1.7.10 all of my
exotics and lately how it gets so many
ninja byte message bags I mean seriously
I'm almost at the point where I'm
deleting them before I even check the
stats as I said earlier you're
guaranteed 36 exotic caches per week no
chance for RNG involved these are a done
deal
in order from least to most if it
required weekly assignment this is by
far the easiest to complete your
complete most of it without even
realizing the most annoying part is
having to complete 10 missions but you
have a week to do it so it's not exactly
difficult completing this will give you
one exotic cache survival assignment
again this one's quite easy you don't
even need to be particularly good at
survival all you need is accused of
score of 20,000 points and survival
before the end of the week this can be
done in one game or ten it doesn't
really matter
completing this will give you one exotic
cache legendary missions the legendary
missions include Times Square power
relay napalm production site and Warren
Gate power plant now these can be a
little bit challenging if you haven't
attempted the before but with a team
that knows what they're doing even a
bunch of randoms it isn't too much of a
job to get through these each week if
you're game these can even be completed
solo if you're interested I've left a
link to a how-to guide in the
description
completing legendary missions will give
you one exotic cash per mission
completed
for a total of three exotic caches
heroic incursions these take the most
effort for a couple of reasons one you
need a coordinated group and two
incursions like Falcon lost can be a
little repetitive in saying that a lot
of teams can't complete clear sky in
around 5 minutes so that mission is
worth looking out for an easy cash per
week completing incursions will give you
one exotic cash per mission completed
for a total of four exotic caches
so that's nine activities that guarantee
you an exotic cache each week if you did
these on all four characters you can get
up to 36 caches per week admittedly this
sounds pretty damn painful but if you're
particularly desperate that shows the
farming potential for exotic caches but
this isn't the only way to get exotic
items there is also a chance to get
exotics through other types of caches to
field proficiency caches underground
caches survival caches and Last Stand
caches these all have a 1% chance of
dropping and exotic I was actually quite
surprised for this as I get an absolute
ton from these particularly their field
proficiency caches if there is a
specific exotic that you're after there
are some that can be targeted through
various missions or activities Barrett's
chess piece dropped by the boss and
Lexington event center at a drop rate of
1% Phyllis holster drops from the boss
and general assembly at 2% Joe Pharaohs
mask drops from the boss in napalm
production site at 1% short bony pads
these dropped from the Madison field
hospital boss at 1% skull MC gloves
these dropped from the light zone bosses
at 1% caduceus and two neighbor a these
dropped from light zone bosses at 2%
warlord and mid bed these dropped from
challenging and heroic mode Falcon lost
and clear sky incursions at 5% golden
rhino drops at 5% from the fire truck at
Dragon's nest builder and error drop at
2% charts from high-value target bosses
hungry hulk and midas these dropped from
the dark zone bosses at 2% drop rate
thompson and tommy gun these dropped
from dark zone supply drops and
contamination events at an unknown
percentage but based on others is likely
to be around 1 to 2% chance the urban
MDR and showstopper drops from
challenging mission bosses at 2%
bullfrog dark zone contamination events
at an unknown drop rate but based on
others is likely to be a 1 to 2% chance
any exotics not mentioned here do not
have a known activity or boss drop
location and can only be found or
acquired by a cash drop
anyone who's watched my videos will know
that I love my cheat sheets and this
video isn't any different I've included
a cheap cheap to sum up everything we've
talked about here at the end of the
video what exotic does RNG keep you from
obtaining let me know in the comments
below otherwise if you found this useful
please leave a like and sub to the
channel if you'd like to hear more of me
prattling on in the next video
Cheers
[Music]